thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Countess of Wessex there in Saint Anne
Square in Manchester meeting the crowds
of people who've come to see them to
pass on their condolences on the death
of the queen and also to meet many of
the volunteers there in Manchester as
well Lisa Dowd is there as you can see
and uh Lisa they really took their time
didn't they Prince Edward and Sophie to
stop and talk to people as they went
along the rows of crowds of people
yes I think they greeted almost every
person waiting on the front row for them
including these ladies here gosh what a
moment that must have been for you you
weren't expecting that today were you
okay no um I was I'm actually in work
and didn't realize that the Royals were
visiting until I saw it on my phone and
I thought well you know what what an
honor and a chance to sort of send send
your condolences which is is what I did
and it must be so difficult for them at
this time so yeah you know it's it's
love it's just lovely and just such a
sad time for everybody and the Countess
had words for for all of you ladies
didn't you she took time to speak to
just about everybody didn't she here and
and the Earl afterwards as well what
does she say to you
she said thank you for coming and
obviously like you just sent your
condolences but like you said she just
had time for everybody
yeah
you come up from London haven't you um
to visit your daughter and just came
across this fact I did and I'm really
glad that I did so I could pay my
respects
um yeah and yeah I'm glad that I'm here
and was able to give
I saw you wipe away a tear
um how how was that moment for you it
was I'm really glad I was here it was
lovely to see Sophie and Shake hand and
she also said this is getting us through
it's getting us through as a family so I
feel really glad that we came to
pay our respects today she said it was
wonderful didn't she to to be here it's
clearly offering them some comfort isn't
it yes I think so yeah yeah why is it
important for you to stop and take a
moment today and to reflect and remember
the queen well I think the queen did a
fantastic job and it's the end of an era
and I think to be here to pay our
respects was just really special today
and I'm really glad I was here two
generations here is it as important for
you to be here as your mum I yeah I
believe so I think it's nice to just
come and support like the royal family
and I think they enjoyed
seeing everyone here as well and seeing
how much less support they do have
really all right and I see people kind
of a there's a bit of camaraderie here
isn't there um nobody was expecting this
today were they I don't know no we
hadn't a clue this was on today we came
in on the bus just on spec and then we
saw this was going on so then we thought
oh well this is an opportunity to go and
pay our respects and there has been lots
of camaraderie it's been really nice to
meet other people here